- [Instructor] "Market
researchers conducted a study
"comparing the salaries of managers
"at a large nationwide retail store.
"The researchers obtained salary
"and demographic data for a
random sample of managers.
"The researchers calculated
the average salary
"of the men in the sample
and the average salary
"of the women in the sample.
"They want to test if managers who are men
"have a higher average salary
than managers who are women.
"Assume that all conditions
for inference have been met.
"Which of these is the
most appropriate test
"and alternative hypothesis?"
And, we can see, they're
talking about a paired T test
and a two-sample T test,
and then they talk about
the alternative hypotheses.
So, pause this video and try to figure
this out on your own.
So first, let's think about the difference
between a paired T test
and a two-sample T test.
In a paired T test, we're
gonna construct hypotheses
around
a parameter for our population
that will often be the mean difference.
So, we have one population,
so we're talking about the
paired situation right over here,
and so, let's say we say,
"Hey, do people run faster when
they wear shorts or pants?",
and so for each member of the population,
you can see what you would,
if you really had perfect information,
you would know, how fast
did they run with pants
and how fast did they run with shorts?
And then, you would
calculate the difference,
and then across the whole population,
you could actually get
that mean difference.
So, the mean difference of pants
minus shorts.
And of course, in order to estimate that,
or in order to do a
hypothesis test around that,
you would take a sample,
and then you would calculate
the sample mean of the difference
of pants
minus shorts,
and then, you would say, "Hey,"
assuming the null hypothesis is true,
you would construct some null hypothesis,
likely that there is no,
that this mean is zero,
and you would say, "Hey, if
the null hypothesis is true,
"that this is actually equal to zero,
"what's the probability
that I got this result?"
If that's below your significance level,
then you would reject your null hypothesis
and it would suggest the alternative
that might be that, "Hey, maybe this mean
"is greater than zero."
On the other hand, a two-sample T test
is where you're thinking about
two different populations.
For example, you could be thinking
about a population of men, and
you could be thinking about
the population of women.
And you wanna compare the
means between these two,
say, the mean salary.
So, you have the mean salary for men
and you have the mean salary for women,
and what you're trying to
do with the hypothesis test
is try to come up with
some conclusions about
the mean difference between
these two parameters.
So, the mean salary for men
minus the mean salary for women.
And our null hypothesis is usually
the no-news-here hypothesis,
and so in this situation,
our null hypothesis is that
there is no difference between these means
and that our alternative hypothesis
in the situation that we are looking at,
because they wanna test
if managers who are men
have a higher average salary.
If they just wanted to
test that whether managers
who are men have a different salary,
then our alternative hypothesis
would look something like this,
where the mean of men
minus the mean of women
is not equal to zero, but
they aren't just testing
to see if the means are different,
they wanna see if men have
a higher average salary.
So, instead of not equal zero there,
we would have greater than zero
for our alternative hypothesis.
So, which choice is that?
Well, we're clearly in a
two-sample T test situation,
and we wanna do the greater than,
not the not-equal-to, so
we are in that choice,
right over there.